тут ми зараз молотимо пшениця фермер
Олександр вольтерс німець але живий і
працює в Україні це його господарство на
Рівненщині близько 4 тисяч гектарів
землі тут вирощують пшеницю соняшник
кукурудзу до ангарів саме завозять
зібраний урожай ріпаку нічого не золото
і цей рік він сама дуже великий Він дуже
великий круглий і цей
менший як Цой дуже малий але є дуже
великий типаку і цей дають високі
олійність так вольтерс говорить
українською чоловік приїхав в Україну
працювати після університету вирішив
заснувати власних господарство тоді ж
зрозумів що не хоче спілкуватися з
людьми через перекладача мови навчила
дружина Українка
что это в кем я вам щось таке я не знаю
це взагалі я ні разу вмію цей і мені
важко якщо їдеш на тоді на Одесу або
щось
Ні я тут ну так як тут люди говорять я
все Олександр вольтерс показує сучасну
техніку сушарку для кукурудзи яку
встановили торік німець розбудовував
своє господарство 14 років тож 24 лютого
не зміг залишити своє творіння
напризволяще чоловік вивіз родину в
Німеччину А сам повернувся тоді я всі
хлопці
господарство давати Вони потім я поїхав
назад і ну нейма добрива треба сипати
хімію мій мусимо наше поле ми 7 сонячний
кукурудза Ми не можемо стаємо або просто
закриваємо все і до побачення так не
робить тут
нині на господарстві міркують як сіяти
озимі і будують плани на майбутнє
будемо потихеньку закруглятися але Супер
молодець молодець що залишився і
працюємо працюємо дальше що робити
у центрі Києва за роботу береться ще
один німець маркус-пойзер він керівник
школи німецької мови на його курсах
навчаються близько 400 студентів нині
здебільшого онлайн куйзер заснував цю
школу в 2017 році коли спонтанно вирішив
з Польщі заїхати до Львова а потім до
Києва
перше враження від українців Вони завжди
вдячні та щирі вони більш відкриті до
спілкування ніж німця це мені тут і
сподобалося і саме тому я вирішив
залишитися в Україні побувши Тут тиждень
я був приємно вражений менталітетом
українців Він дуже припав мені до серця
німець зізнається взимку його
насторожували новини про можливе
вторгнення Росії але він до кінця не
вірив що це станеться 24 лютого чоловік
зустрів у Києві разом із викладачами
школи
ми зустрілися та провели ніч з 24 на 25
лютого разом це була жахлива ніч адже
нам було чути вибухи Ми бачили спалахи
тоді було дійсно страшно Ми вирішили
залишити Київ та вирушили до села під
Хмельницьким де провели півтора-два
тижня потім ми все ж виїхали з України
та попрямували до Польщі та Німеччини
марку спойзер зі своїми викладачами
організував безкоштовні онлайн заняття з
німецької для тих хто шукав прихистку в
Європі їх уже пройшли Близько трьох
тисяч охочих коли в Києві стало
спокійніше німець Без вагань повернувся
Це мій рідний дім мільйони людей виїхали
з України через війну але багато хто
Повернувся через те що я почуваюся тут
як удома Я хочу залишатися у Києві Я вже
звик що моє життя мої цілі в Україні Ось
чому я тут я вірю та сподіваюся що ще
багато українців повернуться
мріє вивчити українську а на запитання
Хто він більше німець чи українець
відповідає так адже
є така собі суміш Я трішки українець і
трішки німець мені ближчий український
менталітет я можу бути типовим німцем
але бути більш українським мені ближче
до душі тим часом на Рівненщині зерно на
господарстві Олександра вольтерса
вантажать на фури аби відправляти до
Німеччини фермер СКА
ржить з не продавав усю продукцію в
Україні але нині тут і так забагато
зерна яке складно вивезти він обурюється
що Німеччина замало допомагає українцям
і за експортом зерна і зі зброєю
[музика]
прийшов українець як як нимці вам я сам
так що це як німці роблять що ним ці
чого наші кансла не дають Нічого я цими
не так скоро з цінним це нічого не міг
нічого не міг рішати нічого не міг
давати нам у привоєнні ризики і
складнощі Олександр вольтерс мріє аби
його господарство було найуспішнішим у
Західному регіоні А для цього
переконаний німець Він має особисто
залишатися тут в Україні